[Music]
let's go to sauna and see it all stop
there it's good to see sana what's up
sana
hi dr john thanks so much for taking my
call you bet what's up um
so well first i just want to say like
i know you call yourself a knucklehead a
lot and this morning i heard you like
kind of take that back you're working on
the positive self-talk i'm trying i'm
trying
i just want you to know that like what
you are doing is so important because
there's so many of us who grew up in
situations where we just have no concept
of what healthy
relationship healthy communication looks
like and i've personally gone through
some counseling for that but i know that
there's a lot of people that like
watching their show they're like
starting to make those connections for
the first time so thank you so much for
that well thank you love i'm grateful
for your kindness i really appreciate
that
um yeah so what's up how can i help
yeah so i'm calling because um my
husband has severe misophonia no no
really
yeah is it for real or is it just um
is it just kind of like yeah yeah you
know what i mean like people just throw
that around social media is it for real
yeah no it's it's for real like it's not
you know like
yeah no like you hear people on on
social media saying like oh i hate the
sound of people chewing it's like no
like this is like actually like a
like a daily struggle for him
like he um okay let me just let me tell
everybody what this is so misophonia is
yeah it is
um oh gosh it's the worst the worst
sounds repetitive clicking noises
chewing sometimes people's voices um
little little things that most of us
don't hear on a daily basis are we here
and can tune out
the last i read on it there's some sort
of connection between that and a
fight-or-flight response
something connected to movement there's
just like a it's like a shortcut in the
brain that is
it's a shortcut to the wrong place right
and it's like trying to take a shortcut
to chick-fil-a and you end up at burger
king like we got to a restaurant that's
the wrong one
and
the smallest thing can send a body into
a panic or into a rage it's just this
const in this little like
or
or whatever whatever like the way people
say certain words can make
it it's annoying to us it is
severely debilitating for folks and so
the reason why i asked you is it real is
no none of us like to have somebody
chewing gum in our ear right and it can
be like that gross whatever
um
but there are others that it's it's a
totally different physiological
experience and you're telling me your
husband's full-on right
it's it's really bad it's
for him man
yeah he um
so like it's it's a daily struggle he
the way he describes it is like
you know once once he hears the sound
and it's the littlest things like i'm
i have like mild to moderate hearing
loss so some of the things i physically
can't even perceive and they are driving
him nuts um but like once once he hears
the sound it's like it
he said he gets all this pent up energy
and it's like he needs to leave the room
he needs to get away from it or like he
says he'll get um
all of this energy like stuck in his jaw
and there have been times that he's like
bit in his own arm or he'll
um if he can't get away from it he's
like scratched himself
so my my physiology may be off okay so
yeah for you endocrinologists who listen
to this and let's be honest there's a
bunch of them not really um
like i may be off here
my understanding which is very very
limited i'm in no way an expert on this
is that it there is a connection between
the auditory signaling system and the
fight-or-flight response and so think
about that energy that he that the way
he's describing that is the is a perfect
way i've i've i understand it and again
i may be wrong i'm not a neuroscientist
but
that his body will flood with adrenaline
cortisol fight-or-flight chemicals his
body is ready for a fist fight his body
is ready to take off sprinting for its
life
and he's sitting there at the dinner
table with his in-laws just chewing
right and so
yeah there's this toggle between
go now
and
dude be cool man that's your wife's
parents chill chill chill right and it
just it's it it's maddening right it's
maddening
yeah oh and you have you have hearing
loss and you're like i have no idea
what's happening here
that is that's the worst sanna oh man
okay so how can i help i'm so sorry
yeah so um he
basically so he
his job right now he's
in a car with his co-worker for a lot of
the day driving from job site to job
site um and so
by the end of the day he's already like
you know at a certain stress level from
from doing with that all day um and then
uh it's the worst
my some of my own speech sounds are
triggering to him
on that
i swear like four or five days a week
he's like i just want to be able to hear
my wife talk
um
it's
like we can't we can't even pray
together without it
like just ruining the
you know the time together um
and so i
i guess i have a couple of things one
like
how do we cope with those moments like
we know
we know a little bit of sign language
and we're kind of like learning more out
of necessity just because it's so
frequent yeah um
but then we run into like the
frustration of not being able to fully
express ourselves too yeah
and then so like how do we cope with
that and like the
you know we will be having a perfectly
good time and then all of a sudden it's
like a brick wall
dropping
you know
and then the other thing is like for me
personally like
you know we want to have kids someday
and i'm like
really worried like how are we going to
handle that if we can barely like get
through
like just talking to each other some
days you know yeah absolutely those are
all super real thank you for sharing
that
yeah
all right so
again i'm gonna preface this i'm not an
expert at this has he gone to see a
doctor before
um
no so when he was in high school uh he
had a psychiatrist who wasn't very
helpful and medicated him for anxiety
and i think that
they you know i don't know that they
listened very well because that wasn't
the problem
and so we're looking for a counselor
i would start with a medical doctor
actually
yeah i would start with a medical doctor
um i don't know
what
pharmaco pharmacological interventions
look like here but there may be and so i
that's where i would start
and i would be super open super honest
but i would be i would that's where i
would start i wouldn't start with a
counselor there's going to be some
relational things y'all got to work
through and i'll talk you through a
couple of those now but i would start
there so um
you mentioned it and i'm glad you
mentioned it the way you did
this is going to be a both and situation
one he has to own
own own he has to own
his global wellness ecosystem
he's got to give his body a chance to
not if but when things
set off his alarm systems he's got some
resilience there that may mean he's got
to have a different job
this is just the way think of this as or
let me put this at he's not making this
up
okay
and for you to not be able to see it and
to just want to say hey i love you and
for that to be what sends your husband
into a panic it's disorienting and it's
it right it's it's really
awful
so i want to tell you if it's real it's
real and it is nobody wants this man if
people feel like they're losing their
minds right like they go to war with
their heads
um
uh
he has to be responsible so i want you
to think of this as though he lost a
foot or he is has some mobility
challenges he's in a wheelchair for a
season like what would you have to you'd
have to do things very very differently
you couldn't just kind of limp through
your normal regular life everything's
different now and so i want you to think
about or him to think about
is he exercising is he sleeping is he
eating right is he reducing his overall
inflammatory response
is he he may have to wear headphones in
the car he may have to tell his
co-worker hey this is ridiculous but i
can't talk in the car um or i've got to
wear these headphones like he's got to
be start being very open and advocating
for himself the same as if he worked at
a place that didn't have a wheelchair
ramp and suddenly he found himself with
mobility issues okay that very safe yeah
um and he's gonna have to be brave about
it he's gonna have to suck it up and do
it and this sucks and it's hard but
that's just what we gotta do
the second thing is is you
are gonna have to
this is hard you're gonna have to
continue to lean into different ways to
communicate or you're gonna have to come
up with some signals or some
gentle ways to lean into one another in
a different way
and i know that's frustrating for you
that's frustrating for him it's
frustrating for everybody
and that's where y'all are
and that might mean that he's going to
wear earplugs and so you're going to
have to talk a little bit louder and but
it'll take some of the sharpness off
it'll take some of that
that burn that happens when when you say
the like the vowels or the consonants in
the wrong way right is that is that what
it is it's usually pieces of words
yeah it's it's usually the consonant
okay all right so um it might be that
you're going to start working with a
vocal coach
and i have to work with a vocal coach
because i talk so much literally um it
may mean that i'm going to y'all going
to continue to lean into it instead of
this being like a beating you're going
to lean into becoming super fluent in
american sign language or whatever the
sign language i want to do we're going
to we're going to do some of these
things
because our life is super different now
i would also recommend
try a weekend babysitting job aft not
now but
wait for a couple of months when he's
got his wellness under control when
y'all are working on different ways to
communicate
um and then i want you all to have a
friend let you keep their kid for a
weekend or an in-law or relative let you
keep your kid for a weekend and you can
begin to practice
because this isn't going to be whether
he loves his kid of course he is and
whether he loves you of course he is
this is going to be
will his body allow him to have a child
in the house
right and so let's just practice that
let's not over overthink it let's just
practice it and see what that's gonna be
like and it's gonna be really tough
y'all gonna have a different set of
challenges the same as if he had another
more visible disability the same as if
you had a more visible disability right
can you do those things because a part
of me wonders are you out are you not
interested in going through all of this
oh my goodness no i'm 100 in ah that
makes me happy good good good good
so what if y'all reframed this
have a weekend of grief
write a letter to misophonia jimmy's
funny you ruined our life you suck we
hate you you've screwed up everything
and we're not gonna let you ruin our
marriage in fact we're gonna use this as
a springboard to be the best married
couple we could possibly be and we're
gonna raise a dope set of little crazy
saunas in the house we're gonna have an
awesome life and you're not taking this
from us
have a couple of days of grief
and then have a couple of days of
planning okay what does this look like
here's our reality the reality is you
can't do this job for 10 hours a day and
then come home and be a present husband
period right and how are we going to
work around that
you can't do this job 10 hours a day and
not have boundaries at work and come
home and be a present father one day
it's not the re it's not the card so you
either you got to do something different
you got your job different whatever
um
and then you all are going to start
working on new ways to communicate
together and i think if you all change
the oh my gosh we're just dragging
ourselves through this instead of
instead of that attitude turning and
facing it and running directly into the
middle of the darkness saying ha ha
we're turning on all the light switches
suckers we're gonna be able to talk
right if you enter with that sort of
attitude we're gonna we're gonna storm
the gates of hell together
man this could be really fun because
you're gonna develop your own way of
communicating that nobody else has it's
gonna be a beautiful interactive way
um
so that's that's the best i can do
please you'll go see a doctor together
who might give you some like oh yeah we
you can take this one thing or there's a
couple of supplements that help with the
auditory response system that help who
knows i don't know where any of that
stands
definitely worth going to see a medical
doctor and then as you all are working
through new ways of communicating it's
going to bring up old stories then you
may want to loot back and meet with a
counselor okay but i'm proud of you
thank you for loving that guy thank you
for being 100 all-in
just got to live a different life now
that sounds so
so dismissive i just changed everything
it's cool
and yeah that's what you gotta do